it's July 5th 2017 so it's time for
another monthly update video I'm going
to talk about what went on in June and
what we've got coming up in July before
that I always like to highlight three
big things each month and some of these
are things that are holdovers from
previous months so big thing number one
a little over a month ago I created a
patreon site to support the work that
I'm doing here in this channel I know
many of you love the videos that you're
seeing and you'd like to help out in
some way there's a lot of work on my
part so if you're interested in that
sort of thing
you can click I'm going to put a card
above and you should be able to see it
big thing number two is also a holdover
from last month I didn't finish up the
Aristotle categories course online
course that I've been developing but I
will be bringing that out this month so
if you've ever struggled with that
deceptively simple text this is probably
something that you're going to want to
enroll in the big thing number three is
in our webinar slash online seminar
series this month we are going to be
tackling jean-paul Sartre and we'll be
looking at Being and Nothingness
portions of it as well as some of his
other writings and we're going to talk
specifically about human freedom and
human responsibility so what went on in
June I should preface all of this by
saying that I didn't get anywhere near
what I had intended to accomplish in
June done but had some very good reasons
for that one of these was that my my
kids are here visiting for the summer
which means that I cut back on my hours
considerably so that I can spend a lot
of good quality time with them we've
been doing some some fun stuff including
going to Summer Fest for one day the
other thing is that over the last week
or so everybody here in the Sadler
shaaka household has been sick myself
perhaps less than them but I've been
doing a lot of you know taking care of
things
and you know quite a bit of things got
get put on hold for the time being so
let's talk about events and things that
took place I continued on with the the
speculative fiction series the
philosophical themes we talked about I N
or Ian banks and not sure how it's
pronounced actually and neither were
most of the participants we talk about
his culture series novels had a really
great discussion you can see the video
for that linked to below we held our
public monthly half-hour Hegel Q&A slash
discussion session that was well
attended and we started something new
involved for patreon supporters of this
channel a philosophy chat where they can
ask me about anything that they want do
this one-hour session once a month for
supporters at a certain level but I open
it up to all of my patreon supporters
for that first month so they could give
a taste of it I also did an online
webinar on Hegel's master-slave
dialectic had a lot of great discussion
during that and another event here
locally in the women you should read
series of the quarterly series at the
Shorewood library we talked about Eloise
and of course that meant talking about
Abelard a bit and we finished up things
by my going to a conference here locally
the Aristotle and the Aristotelian
tradition conference at Marquette
University that went on for three days
and was was quite enjoyable for that
time I actually did have to present
anything I just got to sit back and
listen to what other people were doing I
also did quite a few interviews that
either were done in in May and then came
out in June or I did in June and they
came out in June or early July the most
recent is the think like a thought
leader podcast interview very short but
quite to the point I also did interviews
for stoic metal the painted porch
test and Justin vocalist podcast all
three of those were on aspects of
Stoicism spent a good bit of time
continuing building courses the online
course on Aristotle's categories which
will be coming out this month also did
some course building on Cicero's stoic
paradoxes as well and a lot of behind
the scenes work of course for stoicism
today's we're starting to gear up for
stoic on but also for the SMRT that
we'll talk about in a bit
a lot of tutoring some some coaching and
a good bit of philosophical counseling I
also hosted an online epics conference
for a company that I've been doing some
ethics consulting with and been doing
some writing as well I've got a few
different projects underway one is a
collaborative on stoicism and parenting
that I'm working on with somebody
another has to do with stoicism and
secular humanism but I've also been
working on on a short book of my own I
decided that I really would like to
write something on this whole notion of
in accordance with nature as we find in
the Stoics since its kind of at the
devil the topic and I think a short book
on that could be quite useful video work
I got my six half-hour Hegel's done for
for the month and that took us up to an
into the next section next subsection of
the spirit portion of the work finished
up my core concept videos on Cicero and
in stoic paradoxes which I released and
that of course I've been shooting some
Conte groundwork videos finishing up
that work as well and those are almost
all released at this point I also did a
poll and tried to find out what people
were interested in seeing me do core
concepts on next so I'll talk about that
in a little bit because now we have to
talk about July so what is coming up in
July
um
I'm not going to get quite as much done
again because I have my kids here for
the summer so I've cut back on my hours
and we are still in the midst of some of
us recovering from a kind of tough bog
you that's been going around and a lot
of people around here have been getting
so this may be a little bit
over-ambitious but I will start by
talking about events because I will be
involved with all of those so on
Wednesday July 12th from 5 to 6 p.m.
that's that central time I will be
hosting my monthly half-hour hagel Q&A
slash discussion session you've got any
Hagel related questions or you just want
to talk about dialectical philosophy or
or you know other people in the German
idealist tradition show up and and and
it's open to everybody it's something
that my patreon supporters with a
half-hour Hagel project under right so
it's a public good available to anybody
who wants to be there Thursday the 13th
here in town at the Brookfield library
7:00 p.m. I will be leading the
discussion in our worlds of speculative
fiction series this time we are talking
about Octavia Butler's Zeno Genesis or
Lilith's brood trilogy of books really
interesting stuff on Thursday Tuesday
the 18th of July from 12 to 12:45 we
will have our free online webinar that
anybody can sign up for we'll be talking
about SART freedom and responsibility
that lasts about 45 minutes about 20 of
those minutes are taken up with Q&A and
open discussion so if you've got any
questions about that go ahead and pop in
then following those up on Saturday the
22nd at 10:00 a.m. running till 12:00
and 4:00 p.m. running until 6:00 and
that's all Central Time again remember
we have our online to our intensive
seminars on jean-paul sartre seats are
limited for those so you want to sign up
for that in advance then finishing up
the month on third
day the 27th at 6:00 p.m. here again in
the Milwaukee area at the Shorewood
Public Library we will have our monthly
MKE stoic fellowship meeting and I do
have to mention one other thing that's
right now to be determined Donald
Robertson has asked me to co-host his
stoic mindfulness and resilience
training weekly discussion sessions and
I'm really honored to have been asked
and of course I immediately said yes I
will do that I'm not sure if we'll be
co-hosting or if we'll be alternating on
different times but that that course is
open for enrollment right now it's an
online work at your own pace course but
there is a lot involved in and both of
us Donald Robertson is course the senior
member and myself that the junior member
will be answering questions and talking
about important aspects with the week's
stuff I do have a few interviews coming
up this this month that I don't know if
they'll be coming out this month I'm
being interviewed on stoicism and death
I've got a few online you know email
interviews that I need to finish up my
work on that may be coming out later
this month and I know that I'm also on
deck for philosophy bakes bread podcast
but I think that probably won't air
until a little bit later on I'm not
quite sure I should mention too that if
you're interested in having me come on
as a guest for podcast or or webcast or
whatever it is I'm game for that sort of
thing particularly if it's going to
bring more people into philosophy and
help get across how useful philosophy
can be so just email me at Greg at
reason IO if you want to inquire about
that sort of thing later this month I
will be bringing out the Aristotle
categories online course and I know a
lot of people are anticipating that in
part because the categories is one of
those texts we will often assign
students they read it and they're like
what the hell is this I don't know what
going on here so I'll be I'll be helping
out with that I'm hoping also that I get
the Cicero's stoic paradoxes class
finished up this month and out and ready
as well still doing a lot of tutoring at
least there's there's quite a few things
already booked philosophical counseling
I'm doing some some leadership coaching
as well and I'm doing some ethics
consulting with the business that I
talked about before and with a Institute
for psychotherapy as well so that's
keeping me quite occupied but in in very
good ways yet if you're interested by
the way in tutorial sessions or coaching
or philosophical counseling please go to
my webpage you can you can check that
out on reason IO calm and you'll see
write-ups of each of these activities if
you're interested in that sort of thing
or you can email me directly drag at
reason io comm got some writing project
underway as well so I did do some
blogging last month not as much as I
would have liked to accomplish but I did
get some of it done and I'll be pressing
forward with that some more writing
writing quite a bit more in a Rex st in
a TK writing more in the half hour Hegel
blog writing more in heavy metal
philosopher and also doing some guest
blogging on partially examined life
possibly policy of truth if I if I get
around to it and I have a few other
invitations that if I want to take up I
can do if I can find the time I'm also
working on these book projects trying to
make some good progress on those
particularly the stoicism and what in
accordance with nature means which is
going to be a very helpful book I think
for for many people interested in
stoicism so last thing to talk about and
actually before I go into that is is
videos but I would like to put in one
more plug if you like the sort of work
that I'm doing whether in my videos or
blogging or the other public engagements
that I had
and you want to give something back or
you want to support or you want to make
it possible for other people to enjoy
that become a patreon supporter even if
you just contribute a dollar a month
that all adds up with crowdfunding and
that helps me to provide an income for
myself for all the work that I do and to
provide for my family as well so video
work I have got a lot lined up this
month and it is pretty high-powered
stuff we're just finishing up with the
conte groundwork videos which I think
many people are enjoying that's a very
difficult work another very difficult
work of course is the half hour Haegele
project and we're plowing ahead with
that but we're really doing sort of a
trifecta this this month because we're
also going to be shooting core concept
videos on Martin Heidegger
so I'm going to do some things out of
being in time and then I'm thinking
perhaps you know what is metaphysics or
the question concerning technology or I
might actually decide to do something
different but there's going to be some
hi to your core concepts stuff coming
out this month
I'm also decided I decided I wanted to
shoot a few things on the way as well so
I'm going to shoot some other core
concept videos on Hegel and some on
Gabrielle Marcel to people that I'm
always reading and I'm going to do a
couple other things this month I know
people have been asking for more
personal videos so I'm going to do some
of those and I'm going to start out
doing something something new that I
haven't done before the aunt is book
reviews and I'm going to start with
Massimo Pig Lucchese recent book how to
be a stoic I've got a copy of it that
gets sent to me to review so I really
need to get around to reviewing it and
then I'm going to also do here in
Crespo's book and Epicureanism
and I'll slowly build out from there I
don't know how many of those I'm going
to get done per month but that's going
to be something new I think it's about
time that I started doing some of these
these interesting reviews that
might find useful so that is everything
that is going on this month quite a bit
we'll see how much of it I actually do
succeed in getting to but if I only get
you know two thirds of it done I'll be
quite happy hope all of you have a great
month and perhaps I'll see you in some
of these online events